[Music]
hey everyone welcome to the lobby Mike
McCarty is out this week thank God I'm
hosting
I'm Peter Brown I'm joined by the usual
crew plus y'all Luke from the back hello
how are you today not bad yeah
what do you been up to you um a lot of
playing old games I've I've been doing
these history of features and it's kind
of ruining my ability to play like
current video games and it's so I have
like I haven't played hell-blade yet I
was ever still yeah all these games and
I'm thinking about like my rabbits is
coming out next week Metroid is coming
out soon I'm not gonna have time to play
any of these can you tease what the next
yeah cuz I'm playing every Assassin's
Creed game that's why rough yeah well
enough I don't get too much but the the
pacing of those games can get really bad
especially 3 3 is the worst because I'm
just like okay I just need to get enough
where I can capture footage to show like
the typical experience of this game and
so it's like alright gotta get to him in
the assassins outfit it takes seven
hours to get to that in three you
probably like four hours the dad and
then you play like an hour of him is
like a kid and then you play it three
hours of him has a teenager and it's
like so much prologue yeah and by the
time you finally get to him in the
assassins outfit I like went and checked
the menu and it says like yeah you're
like halfway through the story already
she's like also joined by Kelly plaguey
hello hello and Robert hey Lori hello
you guys look beautiful you doing well
that's a good stop it yeah doing great
yeah yeah cool absolutely alright well
we got a big show today Gamescom is
currently happening and tendo's up to
some stuff Madden is back and we put our
review up last week I got a 9 out of 10
apparently that game is really good
they've introduced like like a story
mode you know I don't know about you but
I really play Madden for the story well
hey hey now I think Alex Niehaus made a
really good argument cuz like you know
football games typically just focus on
the sport right but this story longshot
mode I believe it's called focuses on
the reasons that
the main character like okay why does he
care about football why does it mean so
much to his life what sort of sacrifices
does he make and when he finally meets
like the business end of football what
does that actually mean
you know relative to his dreams and
stuff also this game looks really good
yeah yeah the Frostbite engine at work
does it actually touch him like the more
like cynical aspects of light football
it does to a degree so there I think he
gets to a point where he's on like a
reality game show to be like you know
the next great draftee in the NFL and
he's like why am I here like this is all
manufacturing right like just [ __ ]
like I am I thought I cared about the
game and like what is this this is not
how I want to you know get to prominence
in the NFL what am i doing I imagine it
doesn't go quite to like full-on like
talking about like concussions really
words like 40 years so when he's
catatonic and just got a couch watching
I think it's really cool they put a
story in this I mean that was I think we
talked about this at e3 just um FIFA
having story and that being a really
popular yeah mode and that coming to
other sports games I mean that's the
thing that I think would get me
interested in this and I've never played
a Madden game right now yeah I don't
think these sports games are bad but
like they need a hook other than like
hey Madden's back that game like if you
love Madden like you're gonna play a
regardless but to get new people into it
you need a little something else I think
yeah really good yeah cool so other than
that we are got quake champions really
access generally I know you played some
of that how is shaping up pretty good um
so yeah it's 30 bucks right now to get
early access it the game is gonna go
free to play but I don't think they're
gonna implement that until the game is
fully released so you get like by buying
it you get the champions pack which gets
you access to all existing characters
and every future character right so for
all intents and purposes like to get
like a baseline experience of this game
you're paying 30 bucks which seems fair
has like I want to say eight ish Maps
right now about yeah but like eight
characters added a bj from Wolfenstein
oh really the doom Slayer enough take
and find it but I have footage of the
menus they have some pretty cool
alternate costumes like so they have the
2016 doom layer but they also have his
model from quake 3 arena they have the
doom 3 version of the do marine and then
they also have like the original with
like the ABS like cut out gotta have
them yeah
it's it's really it's really good and
then they have like all sorts of like
custom skins and stuff they they have
like three different things that
currency which is a bit confusing I am
so tired of systems like that yeah it's
I don't really care for stuff like that
but what I it's all cosmetic so ok you
can just kind of play quake and have a
good time and you know I think a lot
people are really worried about the hero
system as far as you know changing up
quake too much but it really doesn't
feel like you know an overwatch or or
even a law breakers where it's more just
like slight tweaks to your play style
so whatever personifies your attitude
maybe more than anything yeah yeah but
like I mean so like you know quake has
like these more in-depth systems like
rocket jumping and bunny hopping and
there are characters that like kind of
make that easier or like better so it's
like this this character is designed to
take less damage when you rocket jump or
this character like moves faster when
you bunnyhop so it's really more just
like what play style of quake do you
like and then that character just kind
of helps you do that better
so it's friggin right cool we've got I
keep saying cool I'm just like Mike
goddamn now I know why he does it yeah
you called you called him out on that a
couple weeks ago I've done it twice
already yeah
what's cool cool cool all right so yeah
Blizzard is also busy they've got two
new animated shorts at one for
hearthstone one for overwatch I'm not
inside under one of those games but do
you guys like this stuff what's your
take I always loved the like the Team
Fortress ones back in the day where it's
like you know you'd get like a little
thing of each character and I kind of
like
they seem to be doing like that but even
a little less tongue-in-cheek and more
like actually like serious like getting
into like the lore of overwatch which is
I don't know I rather have it just be
like a movie is this I haven't actually
watched the short and I I swear to God I
thought this was frozen for a second
there super high quality yeah right it
really goes into the idea of them
building out like a multimedia franchise
around overwatch like I have to imagine
these things are just the beginning
which as well as gonna say it's like I
can almost rather this be a movie like
when they when they did that initial
teaser announcement like when they first
showed the game I was just like wow that
would be like a really good Pixar movie
I've watched that well I like that
overwatch you can jump in and quick play
and you can have your favorite character
or you can get really into that
character and kind of see how they build
it out and this one is May and I know a
lot of people are really big into May
including Tay I think that's correct
yeah and so I think it's smart like
instead of this is the type of game that
people kind of want to drop in and play
and so instead of putting this all in
the game kind of having it be an opt-in
experience I think it's interesting I
mean because a lot of people are like
really big stands up certain characters
and so I don't need to know anything
about you know Bastion huh no that's
wrong I love bastions little bird that's
a lot I was thinking about when that was
around the time when people were just
ripping into mains who were who were
bastions and then I'm pretty sure once
that short came out it was just flooded
with bastions right after yep servers
his little bird is so cute yeah that's a
bad example I don't I don't like Roadhog
I don't like I don't like him so I don't
need to watch a road hog short but I
will maybe that wrote how short could
convince you to love him maybe yeah
maybe and then maybe I try a different
man who knows I seem like it's cool in
the schoolyard gang made fun of or
something like oh god nice I really want
a pot you Mari plush I have a pin
already so anyway I I think it's cool
for sure stuff like this yeah I love it
what about hearthstone is that do
anything for you guys I know nothing
about the Warcraft you know
because it intimidates me is that like
part of official warcraft cannon
hearthstone you're asking the wrong dude
I don't know soon so yeah cuz it's like
it's it's in the universe right and
they've been going at this game for a
while so I have to imagine they're going
to the links they need to to like
incorporate it just feel like I missed
the boat on Warcraft as a franchise and
so anything warcraft related even
tangentially I'm like oh sure but I know
a lot of people really love hearthstone
and that's another game where you could
just play a bunch of games and and then
log off but having this built out for
people who want it is cool yeah and I
Justin hey was pretty stoked yeah loves
that stuff alright otherwise gonna wrap
up the news before we get into the main
segment of the show because we've got a
lot to talk about
crackdown 3 was delayed last week that's
kind of old news by now but that came
right before the Xbox 1x pre-orders
opens and somebody else came up for
pre-order yesterday which we'll get into
a bit later
lots to talk about with that but let's
go to the show we're gonna talk about
uncharted the lost legacy that is the it
was an expansion for Uncharted 4 then it
became a full game myself and Rob we
played a little bit John look he played
the whole thing I made it yeah Miguel
concepción reviewer gave it a 9 out of
10 you thought it was a superb game
liked it quite a lot I found a lot to
love in the the duo of Chloe and Nadine
so we've got his take you can read it on
the site you can check it out on YouTube
what was your take on the game um for me
it's like so it's a as a game I guess
you have to kind of have a certain
expectation going into this you know you
have to I think there are people who
maybe I know about your guys experience
but like if I think if you're going in
thinking like oh man uncharted 4 was
like this grand right you know in scope
and adventure this is that on a much
smaller scale
I mean they've only been making this for
a little bit over a year now yeah and it
was originally kind of meant to be just
like a short little expansion for that
but I think I think it's incredibly
impressive what they were able to pull
off yeah short amount I agree with you
it has sort of like an opening scene
that I was talking to rob earlier today
that was a little bit underwhelming for
me where you're kind of learning the
controls and a market
anyways yeah that stuff's kinda whatever
yeah it was so low-key but it set me up
for like oh crap maybe this isn't gonna
be as impressive as uncharted 4 was but
the the the very next scene where you're
sort of you know running around through
rooftops and different buildings and you
start to see things from new angles and
some you know crazy [ __ ] happens far off
in the background I was like okay here's
the spectacle here's the grandeur that I
was hoping for and it did it's pretty
impressive what they've put in there I'm
only an hour and a half round so far but
apparently there's like a bit of an open
world section that sounds like it jams
from under that stuff's really good um
the Madagascar open world it is pretty
good but it was it was very much it's
still kind of a straight shot it's sort
of like you're following this path and
you can kind of be like oh let's stop
here and you know like look at this
tower for a second then you kind of keep
going I am glad that this open world is
not so much that like that was a very
heavy-handed like you are really just
given the freedom to look around
and here it's it is very open world and
I would say like spoiler free you know
the you you have pretty apparent
objectives you know where you're like a
to be is your bait see like you are
moving with a direct goal in mind and
I'm glad that's the case because yeah I
again Peter - now we're talking a little
bit I really loved uncharted 4 and this
is very much uncharted and it it has
been ramping up for me I have not
finished it but my initial thoughts were
kind of how you use you put it
Gianluca quits like if you're expecting
and uncharted 4 experience a scope and
you know just grand
spectacles all over the world it's not
that I mean for those part I believe it
takes only in India right like it's only
in one location so you're not getting
you know a desert - snow - you know
you're Indiana Jones kind of
globe-trotting it's it's very much the
same visuals but they are extremely
breathtaking the more I've been playing
them where I've been liking it but yeah
at first I like I think I played like an
hour and a half I had to put it down
because I was like not in the mood I
would want to say like just like the
beats like the predictable yeah like you
you just you know okay this ledge is
gonna snap like I felt
a little exhausted from that from four
and I was getting an initial like
reminder of that it's a lot of like hey
you're trying to get from point A to
point B but you're gonna stumble in so
many ways impressively before you get
yeah right did she just roll upstairs
concrete stairs momentum yeah and but
yeah then the other thing is you know I
didn't play this with four I heard this
was you know the shooting people have
given criticism for with Uncharted games
I played uncharted for without that
auto-lock I think most people in this
office even played with it on and I did
that here because I guess another part
of like I know I'm just trying to play
this game for the story right like
that's most Uncharted games you just
want to get through it because the story
and the writing and the voice acting is
always so superb so it has been nice
this time around and I feel like this
game is he's not really centered on
stealth as much as four was known for
it's actually more standard stuff
because really I feel like I most
encounters I feel like oh I don't think
I could have stealth my way I was able
to stealth my way through most of it and
that spoke of you a silenced pistol
which wasn't an option in four it was in
the multiplayer but I guess why me
myself like avoid enemies entirely not
killed
oh there's maybe one area but yes as far
as like avoiding combat completely no I
think they kind of do make you um fight
through and that's fine I really don't
it's not a grep at all but like I guess
I'm saying is like I this time around I
was like you know what I'm not gonna
reset this checkpoint and try to like
pristine my stealth route I'm just gonna
like you know I saw me I screwed up
just keep keep moving forward and that's
fine I I mean I've been doing it the
point of the game like he said is really
just those those story beats yeah and it
reveals so jean-luc I guess you'd only
one who's finish this how do you feel
about what this means for the future of
this series it's obviously like a I want
to say a second-tier game but it's not
like a full production but did you walk
away thinking anything about these
characters would be great in another
installment oh yeah definitely the
characters like the they're really good
pairing you know you think like oh like
what's an uncharted game without Nathan
Drake and you're like this is a pretty
good case for like how you can keep a
series like in charted
moving forward with like good characters
like Naughty Dog just knows how to write
good characters oh yeah I know this is
standalone I haven't played an uncharted
and that isn't because I'm not
interested in them I just haven't
haven't gotten around to it is this
something I can jump into or should I
absolutely I've only played for and even
then I didn't really pay attention to
that characters particulars too much so
if you're interested in going back to
four though it does take place after
four so it kind of inherently some
spoils certain aspects of that right so
place first I didn't even know it did
take place after four it becomes more
apparent later on to make reference your
night stuff yeah like it's almost like
if you had played for your gang a little
bit of like those like kind of I know so
far in my like three hours I've had it
feel like oh the the Drake brothers like
you get a couple of moments like that
okay cool but it's nothing that like is
you know it's not pivotal you play that
game I don't know no definitely not for
me though like the big thing was
actually that open-world section was
just like seeing the this kind of like
freeform it reminded me a lot of like
the first Far Cry or like Crysis where
rather than it's like that the thing I
don't like about open worlds like true
open world games is that you end up
pacing and narrative can kind of end up
getting like screwed over by that like
in a game like Uncharted which is very
much about like that tight pacing a
narrative where this feels like a really
good balance where it's a series of
linear of a series of levels that have
like a very clear like objective and end
point but within that level you're given
this freedom to like move around and
explore and I would almost I would love
to see an inch arted game be entirely
that like just a series of different
like open-ended levels that you're given
like a lot more freedom to explore yeah
I'm like I think that would be really
cool like they should take that concept
and like push that further or like maybe
even Last of Us could incorporate stuff
like that like I'd like to see more of
that anything notable to say about
multiplayer because it's basically
uncharted fours multiplayer not so it's
yes just in her for us they added
a couple skins the survival mode from
for in there I think it's got like some
new modes and that I had a pretty sick
to run last night yesterday on our
stream with today you can pull that up
what was the deal I had a shotgun and I
just wrecked some fools it was good what
was your streak how many kills five or
six
I assume that's good based on the noises
that's wrong that's two and then this
guy runs past me like an idiot that
finisher kick is very rewarding now it's
just funny because again the first match
was like really bad and I was like just
give me one more one more
yeah it was like a guy wearing like a
daft Punk helmet like a diaper and I'm
just running around it's like standard
Chloe I'm like this game got weird with
did you know I cannot die Rob is
obsessed with craft Punk a character
that you must watch YouTube it's Eric
Andre show craft
I'm obsessed that's my halloween costume
about to bring up graphics that makes
for an easy transition that's right next
Kelly you went to the Pokemon
Championship in Anaheim yeah very
similar to craft Punk in a lot of ways
yeah the Pokemon world championships
happen every year this year they're in
Anaheim
I've been going for a couple years now
and it's very cool they play the trading
card game and the video game and this
year there's also pokken tournament so a
lot of high level playing going on also
side
tournaments and stuff for people who
either are spectating or who got knocked
out early on in the term until there's
it's really cool this is the the finals
from the video game which was very very
exciting in ways that are too long to
explain I think but it's thick of it
right here yeah but I love the Pokemon
world championships because
it's you know really really high-level
dedicated players a lot goes into
building a deck for the TCG and for the
video game you could spend 50 hours
breeding and training a team to get
ready for competitive and so people are
very serious but nobody is a bad sport
they're a lot of kids there's three
divisions this is the masters division
it's based on gears but usually it's
like people over 18 and the youngest
people are like 8 9 year olds being
amazing at Pokemon and I just love it
because everybody is so happy to be
there and just welcoming lots of
families and I can't want to ask what
the atmosphere yeah that while you're
talking about it because so many you
know competitive gaming things
especially those that have been around
for a while and keep going there's a lot
of like spectacle and sort of like you
know huge it's a big event there's a lot
of things sort of held up around it but
you never really see that with the
Pokemon Championships from the outside
it seems like it's an event that's very
insulated is that like an effect of the
younger crowd like this isn't a game or
the players are making millions of
dollars they just love this game and
they love Pokemon yeah I mean the
trading card game I think the top the
first-place prize is 25 grand and it's I
think 10 for the video game so you're
not competing for a ton of money up
until last year it was just scholarships
and I added cash recently um but yeah a
lot of people just really love it and
it's not a huge spectacle until the last
day because like this match everyone was
sitting down watching screaming at
different crazy things that were
happening it was it was crazy watching
this live with a huge crowd but the days
before that Friday and Saturday were
just people kind of playing pickup games
in the hall and you know some people
kind of sitting in the crowd watching
the semi-finals a lot of people were
there to play and to talk to their
friends who they don't see it's really
international this was a match between
Australia and Japan and so people just
see friends they only see once a year
and so that that's really the focus of
the event so there isn't he they're
wearing their flags I think yeah define
and so that's what I really like about
it is there's not a lot of I mean
there's pressure but you can I enter it
into a side tournament that was just
like $10 to enter at 4:00 p.m. we all
meet up in this area and it's really
informal it's just like oh we're here to
play pokemon are there any like
showboats like real jerks yeah a hotel
like we've all been there one of the
winners like a pokemon card game like he
he got his first place status revoked
cuz he like shat and like the hotel
lobby or something joke I don't know can
you imagine being that second-place
winner he's like yeah I got second place
but I'm coming on with the first now
because I do not recall that half and I
definitely recall that happening what
villains do you recall okay so there are
some kids in the middle school range
that were testing me they were testing
my patience whoa no I can john mulaney
said it right those are some of the most
cruel they're scary
people they know exactly how to do this
yeah deeper I met this like go ahead
no don't that's the thing you don't like
about you the thing they don't you don't
like about yourself they know they'll
call it out so I'm entering into a side
tournament it's different from the
format for the video game championship
so it's just like a free-for-all it's
battle royale which is a Sun and Moon
like a new mode descendant moon so I'm
just doing this for fun I sit down at
this like just you know temporary it's
almost like a lunch table I feel like
I'm at lunch in elementary school and
there's like kids everywhere and I'm
like I'm ready to destroy there's also I
was beating there's these two kids that
are just there they had they're talking
in secrets and they have their little
secrets like pig latin they were kind of
like we know something you don't know
and I'm like I'm an adult I know a lot
of things my taxes but also it's like
also you're like you're probably like
your inhibitions were high because their
parents were
behind Emerson there right there hurt so
it was like a girl who's probably like
12 13 and a boy was like 13 14 and like
so there was actually it was actually
kind of cool because they were like I
thought they knew each other I thought
they were friends and they came together
but they actually met there and found
out they had traded online before it was
actually pretty cool small world
but they were being like these Pokemon
definitely aren't hacked hahaha and I
hacked Pokemon is like what Pokemon has
illegal move sets that you get by
plugging in your thread yes to a program
and so there's like things like one hit
Kos that are totally illegal to play
with in a competitive environment and I
was not having it that sounds like mind
games like I've been playing this game
for 20 years I I can't lose to you and
these kids have so there's a Machamp
which you probably knows it's the first
generation Pokemon if you're not
familiar with Pokemon that camera and it
has a movie called Fisher in the early
games which is a one-hit ko but it has
like a 30% chance of hitting and machamp
can also have an ability called no guard
which means that all of its moves have a
hundred percent chance of hitting but
any moves have a hundred percent chance
of hitting it so it's like a opportunity
cost sort of thing but if you have no
guard in Fisher which is impossible in
Sun and Moon but you could hack in a
Machamp with no garden Fisher you will
just sweep the floor with everyone and
so I was not having it I was sOooo so
mad and this girl's like this this
freaking girl it's like it took Pokemon
and then she didn't even bring a charger
for her three yes like she wasn't even
prepared she had no idea and like her
dad had to like hook her up to a laptop
and all this stuff and I was like okay
and then I just I just destroyed the
Tally's of all our kills and every time
I kill these kids Pokemon I looked them
directly in the heart but anyway this
tournament I got second place and the
first place winner was this like guy
from Japan who was who just like
destroyed everybody dang but I it sounds
like you had your own battle that you
I did that's all man and you know I
accomplished what I came to accomplish
so yeah so there's snot-nosed kids like
that but for the most part they're
lovely is there any news that came out
of the event
did they ever like do anything like
reveals they they haven't done a really
big reveal since 2015 in Boston when
they announced pokken tournament coming
for consoles this one was just kind of
like oh there's a new Z move and that
doesn't matter to anybody except people
who it was really cute that the juniors
champion so he must've been 10 in the
video game he's like from Australia and
they're doing this interview with him
and he's all shy and he like isn't
looking at the camera and she's like
alright well what do you want to say to
everybody watching at home in Australia
and he turns to me and he goes well I
guess our country's the best like the
whole crowd is like crying he's so cute
there's a lot of fun I wrote a recap of
the actual battles if you are somebody
who's interested in battles and how and
knows a little bit about the I mean like
if I try to explain it it would be a
bunch of words that don't make sense so
yeah if you're interested in that I did
write then it there's also the demo for
pokken tournament DX coming to switch
today I think so
all those hungry switch owners you think
the tournament has the potential to
increase in production when they make
the switch game and possibly I think so
I really think there is a high barrier
to entry for competitive Pokemon in a in
a way that's different from other
competitive games because it's like a
the reward isn't the same right um the
reward is more of a community type thing
and so people aren't going to really
invest as much time as they could but it
does take a lot of time to get into I
think I have a hundred fifty hours and
in moon and like a lot of those was just
riding around breeding pokémon getting
ready for battles yeah the theme of like
getting those random chance attributes
it's not even attributes though right
it's like something else that informs
how attributes grow yeah so I also wrote
an explainer for competitive video game
Pokemon if you are interested in
you can get back home but yeah you you
are breeding for hidden stats abilities
natures and moves so there's hidden how
do you know you're in southern room they
added a way for you to check it in your
PC so they they used to be extremely
hidden you had to kind of there was like
one guy who would tell you and he would
that's always the thing is like there's
a guy like it's like well if you go to
this part that have you talked to this
one guy he'll be like your Pokemon seems
happy and you're like yeah so that means
that it has this thing and there's all
these like invisible stats and charts
dude it's like oh my god like it's a log
it's a lot I have an app where I keep
track of all of my Pokemon and what
stats I bred onto them and how I trained
them it's a high investment with switch
if they I mean that with with Sun and
Moon they made that a lot easier somehow
because it still sounds very complicated
when I explained it but they made it a
lot easier than in past years if they
continue to make it easier to get into
the competitive scene then maybe I could
see it what do you think and even the
spectacle like like the switch has the
chance visually to be like so much more
interesting looking like you look at
like the game it's like okay well we had
to blow up a 3d F screen yeah like maybe
some people look at that they're like
it's just like 2d sprites like yeah it's
hard to tell from the outside looking in
that this has the depth that you're
describing because it looks rudimentary
and then you also see like characters
have like three attacks yeah so the very
leaves with the switch version even
though it still might not it still may
be hard to tell how much depth there is
at least the spectacle they could
potentially look way more exciting and
that would just get people more
interested in at least watching it we're
so gone watching like a Pokemon battle
right absolutely
especially with Sun and Moon I was so
sure they were going to come to switches
ports because they look like they are
higher definition than the 3ds can
handle almost definitely that framerate
was real bad well the frame rate I have
an original like 3dsxl I don't even have
a new 3d s so like mine chugs in some of
these battles and so I thought oh you
know they're just preparing for a switch
which just turned out to not be the case
but I imagine if they made it a little
more streamable Xtreme friendly right I
think the problem with the trading card
game is it's a top-down view
and then there's kind of this you can
see the people's prize cards from under
it's the production value is not what
you would big use to because the if
you're watching like hearthstone or
something there's a there's an actual
like online video game component the
Pokemon Trading Card Game Online looks
like a knockoff app like it's a really
garbage so they're not gonna stream
using that so I think they do suffer
from production value issues with some
stuff but yeah I love it a lot
III bought a new 3ds finally to replace
links I was like I can't keep breeding
pokémon on this broken 3ds and the
circle pad broke off and so I did
reinvigorated my love Pokemon and that
is what truly matters so what's the deal
with ultra Sun and Moon that comes out
pretty soon is that are you gonna pick
that up does that make a difference for
someone like you who's already put so
many hours into yes yes so the
competitive series for 2018 will be
played in ultra Sun an ultra moon so
anybody who wants to enter into
tournaments has to have that game I
think they haven't really announced the
official rules but so for this year your
pokemon had to be bred and or caught in
a lola so you couldn't import old
pokemon from like omega ruby and alpha
sapphire which bummed me out because i
had a bunch of really perfectly trained
pokemon in that game that couldn't use
any of them but because ultrasound ultra
men are also a lola i think you could
probably just trade your pokemon up or
put them in Pokemon bank and use them so
it might make it a little easier for
people who had Sun and Moon already um
but I mean it I'm interested they they
haven't really done like alternate
versions of existing pokemon games i
mean the the they broke the mold with
black 2 and white 2 where it was a
stable so I'm not entirely sure I will
of course play it I think this I mean I
haven't seen much but it feels like this
is maybe more in that vein because
there's like new trainer use it yeah it
seems like the stories may be gonna be
different
hopefully they make the beginning of
that game faster because it takes like 2
hours to get to the first Pokemon Center
right yeah issue
I like Sun Moon a lot but I think I'm
I don't know if I'm gonna get ultra I
think I might just wait for the switch
one at this point yeah yeah yeah I I
really like Sun and Moon I thought they
were a great balance of things for you
know the typical Pokemon player and the
competitive pokemon player and that's
what I think they did really well with
that game and stuff they continued they
tweaked a couple things I'm really
hoping personally that there would be
better move tutors because they don't
have a lot in Sun and Moon and your
pokemon can't learn cool moves that way
so that's the thing that's very specific
like a tutor move tutor yes so there's
like certain moves that your Pokemon
can't learn from learning from leveling
up okay but if you wanted to because
there's only four move slots you have to
be really careful about what moves you
put there which is part of the depth of
that strategy as being like okay what
are the most efficient moves and what
can I do to avoid these traps that
somebody could set me up in and a move
tutor will have a really powerful move
that unlike oh that'll be perfect for my
set like I'm really bummed because my
favorite Pokemon Umbreon and an alpha
sapphire you can teach Umbreon foul-play
which is a really good move for embryo
me you can't teach it that in moon my
Umbreon sets ruins Pokemon there's a lot
of stuff coming out the championships
were there you can check out coverage on
GameSpot you said have competitive
explainer recap and people were using
your favorite first generation Pokemon
so I wrote about that as well nice I
liked your whatever that was that was
very good I thought I didn't realize
which camera I've been struggling with
it's all good
so Nintendo's very busy it's not just
Pokemon the Super Nintendo classic is
also on the way as I'm sure everyone on
the internet found out yesterday and the
chaos continues these things sold out
like crazy but the things started off
horrible because Nintendo it wasn't
yesterday it was the night before at
like 10:00 p.m. was a Best Buy that went
first Best Buy had pre would have opened
just by one first and then Amazon like a
couple hours late for it I was asleep
yeah I woke up and everyone's like oh
sweet I got my supers
yeah good thing I was up between like
what yeah so this is the yeah the NES
classic stuff was bad this just seems to
be indicating that it's going to be just
as bad now it is just pre-orders but
yesterday when it opened up it started
with a tweet that was saying something
to the effect of Oh
GameStop stores in Australia or
something are gonna put them up at 10
a.m. or something like that and then
everyone's like ok well if they're gonna
sell them there maybe they're gonna sell
them at every store around the world you
know yeah sure enough at 10 a.m. it was
Best Buy it was Target it was gamestop
who is Amazon Game Stop went down their
site crashed Best Buy sold out very fast
target the same I had a stupid score
Project Scorpio Xbox sitting in my cart
cuz like when they announced that I was
like maybe I want one no I don't and I
just closed the tab I had tabs on my
browser yesterday ready for all these
retailers to get my stupid you can see
the the image when the game games
stopped got a write website went back
online it was like this banner that said
like pre-order the Xbox one exit Scorpio
before it's gone and then underneath was
just a rather banner that just said like
senesce classic and then giant letters
sold out right like yeah we know what
you're here for
yeah don't bother that damn Scorpio in
my cart when I was at Target I got to
the checkout process it was like cool
your totals like $600 and I was like
wait why oh [ __ ] I got to get rid of so
I hit delete and then the little wheel
of time and effort just kept spinning
and I was like was like 2 minutes so
like like right at 10 we have like our
meeting and I was like hold on guys and
I was like okay I just need remember my
my Walmart password right I logged in
and like maybe 30 seconds but it was 30
seconds too late cuz they were already
gone yes seconds is all it takes for
that tank screwed up I would like to say
that I appreciate the situation we're in
where if we have a 10:00 a.m. meeting
everyone will say hold on we have
important business to take care of so I
had poster going on seeing the Eclipse
no we're doing a meeting sorry I had a
broken desks I'm talking you guys about
getting a desk at home and anyway I was
working at home yesterday partially so
that the people could come take the
broken desk away and what time were they
showing up at like 955 but like places
like Target it was like ten fifteen or
so when they went live so that wasn't a
huge issue but it was that moment where
I was like really universe that's what's
gonna happen because they called me like
fifteen minutes before to say oh we're
gonna be there in ten it's not fun
there's nothing fun about it like that I
had like a certain excitement to like oh
I'm gonna go to you know wait in line to
get my halo three Master Chief legendary
hey [ __ ] like that every two anniversary
steelbook every game I got it or had ten
go down there you could sit and you
could chat with some guy in line talked
about said to you already go play Halo
yeah this you're just like sitting at
your desk you're angry you're angry tiny
video game system I was about to say it
really is a metaphor for sighted I'm
going out at midnight I'm gonna buy a
game at midnight now I'm like I just
want to go to bed no [ __ ] Nintendo this
wouldn't happen well yeah so they said
that they're gonna be making
significantly more especially for launch
day mm-hmm I love the mind that like
fingers crossed right that this is just
a pre-order nonsense that like this is
what people are dealing with now and
Nintendo is quietly like I wish everyone
would just relax because we're gonna
have plenty more I feel like they're
gonna be able to meet demand because
there's whole story with the NES classic
was we didn't know how many people
wanted it and by the time like
manufacturing contracts and all that had
been worked out it was like well we got
discontinued this thing again or even
like the fact that the Valda pre-orders
that were cancelled
hey your demand is pretty apparent like
make sure you your second run is gonna
be like legit although I mean I I guess
I get why Nintendo would want to kind of
play it safe I mean I don't know maybe
the the memory of the Wii U is still
fresh where it's like oh geez I guess
you got to imagine though like the
reactions
cuz then his classic came out why like a
year and a half ago or something yeah
yeah that's quite a lot of time and
people have been like fever pitch that
things since it came out
I think they know I don't think they're
trying to like like some people think
like drum up scarcity you do like sort
of create this like weird demand and
hype I don't know they keep making this
mistake we amiibos like it's a repeated
pattern that they keep making sort of
certain point I'm like there's I think
there's a combination of what you guys
are describing here because they
couldn't do it that way right but then
they're just gonna have angry customers
right right but they also don't want to
make too many because of too many
products are sitting on the shelf it
kind of looks bad yeah at that point
maybe not that it's maybe not a problem
of them being able to afford the loss
coz like I'm sure that we you hit their
bank real hard oh yeah I'm sure but but
yeah at the same time they got a they
have to control the marketplace a little
bit with like how their shelves right
I remember how impressed everybody was
and this probably was a product of how
old I was at the time as well but when
the we was super hard to get yeah I
remember like my dad had to go to a
store like 30 miles away and you could
only buy one right and like you I
remember like everyone was like wow the
we is so cool and that was probably
because I was like I don't know 14 or
something yes I'm so young but I I mean
like if you strike that balance well it
can be beneficial to you yeah but I
don't know my faith in Nintendo with
certain practices wavers a lot
especially with like online stuff and
then since they keep doing this with
amiibo and with the switch and with the
NES class like I'm just kind of like
there's certain mistakes they're making
that seem like the products of not
having enough knowledge yeah so I'd hate
to jump from that ship and then say but
they're also ultra clever right and you
know they also have to look at the
prices that these things are going for
on eBay
like people are paying $300 for a Super
Nintendo classic Nintendo is only
charging 80 there's got to be something
to take away from that yeah it's not
like they're getting them right well
they don't see that Roth
yeah yeah of course yeah so I don't know
I don't know how you you take that and
sort of factor it into what the hell is
going on here but it's a mess and it's
too bad because this thing has a almost
flawless game library it is I mean the
NES classic has a lot of stuff that
people aren't nostalgic for but not
necessarily all those games on the NES
classic are great to play today I would
argue that 99% if not all of the games
on the Super Nintendo classic are
probably still really good to play today
the one exceptions might oddly enough be
Star Fox and Star Fox 2 because those
are early 3d games that are pretty
rudimentary they're not like Brian these
you know I don't wanna say perfected but
near perfection 16-bit 2d experiences
they are a rough starting point for
where we are today I mean like link to
the past is so fun I think we talked
about this before the main the glaring
omission for me would be Chrono Trigger
yeah but everything else it's like
that's a game I can't wait to play yeah
yeah because I got one no didn't get
well I actually might give it to when
you guys I don't know if I want that
much and for those for those of you
don't know well because I knew the
demand I was in bed at 10 p.m. and Ben
jakka and the slack was like they're up
and I like rushed my computer and then
bought it and went back to sleep I know
Joey got to but you were already asleep
but then he I was super tired old times
you have a Syrian I'm sorry that came
off very snide so cool I think some I
think Miguel said he might have an extra
one that I can buy off him so I couldn't
buy he had an extra switch that's how I
got my switch hook up but I mean Best
Buy I didn't leave you buy more than one
Bret I could have done a different
credit card though huh different name
Roberto
[Laughter]
I don't know what else there is to say
about this thing make them easier to get
in Tendo please and make the cords
longer make the core I think they are
longer this time by a few I feel like by
a few feet oh I thought it was less I'm
not that significant but I was like an
inch or two sorry sorry if I don't feel
like three to five feet which is still a
little bit short but that's the Super
Nintendo classic kind of short in all
regards I guess and it's amazing how
something like this a product that isn't
out yet that we can't buy is
overshadowing a big convention where
things are being announced that you will
be able to buy down the road because
Gamescom is happening right now in 2017
we've got some crew on the ground there
hasn't been a lot of news yet the show
is still kind of going Microsoft was the
thing that really kicked it off though
how did you guys feel about their
presentation cuz I know it was a bit
lackluster I didn't I didn't watch it I
was home and then I was like oh yeah
that presentation happened I went to
like check on the news and I was like oh
cool nothing drastic world Brassica well
the other dress was interesting actually
does yeah that sounds like mean of like
the theme park kind of rollercoaster
tycoon games that sounds very fitting
that already exists I feel like that's
such an obvious concept what like zoo
tycoon but drastic park yeah I mean
there were dinosaur mods for zoo tycoon
I was a big zoo tycoon fan and as
someone who is currently wearing a shirt
with dinosaurs and I must say I'm very
excited about this particular
announcement so that this is really the
only thing that I was even remotely I
mean it's an unexpected it's an
unexpected game from Microsoft which is
unexpected because they not the harp on
them too much but look we've got four
top we've got Age of Empires oh I need
that we've been we've been seeing these
series for a long time and they keep
bringing back things sweet but everyone
knows so to see something like this is
very delightful but they didn't even
have the sequels for the series that a
lot of people you know maybe are waiting
for which is too bad like I got a feel
for people who are stoked for the
Scorpio because they're gonna pay five
hundred dollars for a system that is
just gonna play I mean look it'll play
some games
in other systems but it's not gonna have
that you know you get a new console you
have that I attach the attach part like
the this thing is the this represents
the games I'm going to play the ones I'm
already excited for and I don't know if
this is the game that's really going to
do the whole this is nothing coming out
until next year sure oh there you go
that's what I've been waiting for since
I was like two years later so excited
and there's something really cool about
like making a park I'm assuming making a
part park and it's just like hey your
fences are down is your Park is my Park
was like failing or something cuz I was
like eight I would just break the fences
and let the Tigers just I mean it's the
the Scorpio is cool right it should have
more games I think because it's a it's a
really powerful console it looks really
nice as well
that's got a lot going for it does it's
it's pretty like I it's one of those
things like want it to be loved yeah
it's frustrating to see it not get what
it needs like I get sad about it
not as sad as I do when I think about
battleborn I get really sad when I think
about battle I love that he's wearing
clothes but yeah I know but like look at
how sleek that is and like its yeah I
want I want it I loved my 360 so much
just like I was
I love the controller there's a lot I
like about Xbox ya know I mean you'd and
there's obviously like you know new
console lust as well like that fresh
hardware like it of course we want that
like look at this thing it looks like
Dan it's like a modern take on the ps2
it is almost the same aesthetic oh yeah
very similar to the Xbox one ass but
when you look at it like this and black
it's like yeah I'm looking at the yeah
it's got the same also not much activity
going on at Xbox
[Laughter]
we're gonna crack down get up you're out
yeah I don't want to sound like we hate
X no it's just sad to see something like
this that that should be really exciting
to sort of not have I think it's really
cool that they're releasing a special
version that's a calling back to like
the code name project Scorpio instead of
Xbox one X because it's like this yeah
you get so many systems like the Wii was
supposed to be the revolution right for
Nintendo and I love that name and they
said we I was like why didn't you just
stick with revolution like for some
reason I wanted that PlayStation you
know yes so like that would this is the
equivalent this is a special edition
that brings that that forward you know
thing forward one little detail you
mentioned cuz I watched part of this is
if you feel around the back like you
know a typical Xbox if you're plugging
in the HDMI cable you have to like
really look to feel like ok which one am
i plugging it into the well but the ps4
has one HDMI connection oh let's process
too right yeah so there's a raised lip
around the HDMI for the one that you
want to plug it into now that's cool
marzia
you eventually know what which one is
which no you're smart broad but that is
cool I do like that am I the only person
who sometimes I'll like be trying to
turn on my ps4 and I'll hit the eject
button like I still have trouble with
that like I'm never going to learn which
one is the HDMI IN so I I'm happy there
aiding someone like me that just is very
forgetful there you go it's a smart
little design touch yeah hopefully they
dude that with the UI - ok the
sensitivity on the on switch is not so
damn high when I just speaking of that
can I tell you a really cute thing about
my dog my dad plays a lot of Call of
Duty and when my dog wants him to take
her out for a walk she knows how to turn
the Xbox up with her nose really what
does he do just she couldn't reach it
it's like it's like the have Pavlov I'm
saying that wrong yes Pavlov a blob
practice where it's like it's the noise
of it turning off yeah he's like the
reward he turns the Xbox off because he
has it on a lot and she turn it off
herself with that touch button so if he
got this she wouldn't be able to do that
as what I'm saying
so Gamescom still going is are we
expecting anything else big out of the
show I should know that I'm leading this
freaking stream right now but what do
you guys know Germany is a lovely place
and I'm loving seeing everyone's
pictures from Germany okay would like to
mention that QuakeCon is also coming up
to I think there's some overlap in like
in announcements John Luke you were
going I'm going it's gonna see
Dishonored
mm-hmm deftly outsider and evil within
two both of which are coming out very
soon like Dishonored it's like September
15th really yeah like I was like oh it's
like November or something and I was
like oh no it's like less than a month
yeah Wow really we have evil within like
yeah October 13th or something like yeah
yeah yeah there's gonna be pretty soon
other not too much though from like
quake on cuz it's mostly you know like
quick just party whenever early access
though I like some tournament stuff
there but mostly it's like best was kind
of done with their their major
announcements for the rest of the year
yeah we'll have some games come clean up
at PAX West right so which I'm also
going to I am going to that as well so
see when is that happening that is not
this weekend but next weekend so yeah
but as far as games come goes I mean I
know around here we were very prepared
for Xbox and then that didn't turn it to
have a lot of news that at least we were
excited I don't want like ten people
here and pizzas ordered yeah yeah yeah I
mean I mean it was the same trailers
right from right which is I heard about
that
I wasn't Pokemon I didn't see this but I
heard it would be like who's grabbing
this trailer oh wait this is the e3
trailer mm-hmm kind of stuff I am yeah I
am like optimistic I guess in the sense
it like I I mean I want to see you this
release I want to see like it you know I
don't know if it'd be worth it but I
mean down the road to like
you know you kind of said it like an
exclusive right like like halo next year
I went I need new things from Microsoft
I agree I agree but that's something
yeah it is at least like in my history
I've bought a console or an Xbox Jesus
like four times
Xbox Jesus Jesus I bought it is like a
system that red rings and then comes
back the next day I bought my Xbox one
for Master Chief collection that was
rata that was rough
yeah as a rough one but 360 twice for
Halo 3 and then I think was four but
anyways like I yeah this time around is
just like there's it's not there right
like I it maybe was gonna be crackdown
but I don't even think that game was all
that great like I mean that's almost
good that if they're gonna delay that
I'm happy for it because like what
gameplay came out someone had posted
gameplay didn't didn't look all that
modern I think the the trick which we
talked about before is gonna be in the
multiplayer the cloud-based where
everything is destructive in the
environment and it really is like
everything like it is it's not just like
oh a door falls off its hinges it's like
the door can crack in half and like
crumble like it's yeah it's pretty
impressive for an extent to which things
can can happen so in terms of looking
modern and new I have to imagine that's
the sort of thing that they're they're
trying to focus on is get that part
right right but I mean the the other
thing is like I continued to play on
xbox because I had friends to play with
on xbox and like I don't know about you
guys but like switching to ps4 for
multiplayer stuff was primarily a oh
well although everybody I know is on ps4
kind of decision I don't know how you
reverse that except with like a
compelling multiplayer experience that's
exclusive to Xbox I don't know I don't
know really where I was going with that
no you're on point I think that's almost
quinces an altar like wasn't there story
this morning about I mean it is what it
is but it was like
more talks with Microsoft and Sony on
cross-platform that's that it was a
headline I don't know Sony intends to
just say no we don't want to do that
yeah yeah bummer mm-hmm but hopefully
some better news comes out at Gamescom
certainly gonna be a lot of trailers
because even if it's not the huge stuff
from people like Microsoft there's a lot
of games that you know fall middle we
should be hearing about those last seven
for the show we're gonna talk about
maybe one of the biggest series called
duty called duty world war 2 not world
at war which I call it during the
meeting a few times today maybe I got
some new modes and I know at least you
got to try some of them Rob are you the
only one did you go as well I didn't go
but I did play some modes at e3 all
right so war mode that's the one that I
think maybe we should talk about first
because that's actual like you know big
fundamental change for Call of Duty in
terms of how matches work right yeah
absolutely it was the yeah do they had
three maps this is gonna be the same
beta that's gonna be coming out this
Friday three Maps your standard call
duty modes
you know like domination king deathmatch
hardpoint yeah and then the new one is
war zone that was the one that grabbed
me the most because it was the most
unlike Call of Duty here we were looking
at whatever this is just domination we I
started playing these modes in the event
I went to and I had to find time I liked
you know again we're going back to its
roots right just simplistic Call of Duty
World War 2 easy to play easier
understand for the most part I did like
that that was refreshing to a point but
there's there's something I would say is
where I got a little tired was I within
like a my first match I found myself
like looking at the same they're doing
the same things because it's a lot of
these maps are these namely these three
were I felt a little small or was like
the most part like three lanes like I
found myself just looking at the same
stuff I don't know this map action was a
little bigger I for than aiming this one
um like point dew point yeah but yeah
war zone was with some
I really liked because it actually gave
me the the world war two that like I
feel like this is the aesthetic in
general like you know like access allies
with distinguished spawn points and
sides for those who don't know this mode
basically it's like three stages
objectives it's very similar to battle
field ones operations where you start
off with the Allies are advancing they
need to attack this house ahead and the
Germans are defending it if the Allies
break through the house you move on to
the next objective which is a bridge the
Allies need to build so they're you know
you have you're gonna have people
defending you can have people trying to
build a bridge you can as Germans you
can set up in almost like nazi zombie
ways like put up barriers put up machine
guns which is very different and I like
that idea it was so cool my favorite
part of war mode was that I was using
loadouts that I wouldn't normally use
and like I play a lot of TDM and I don't
snipe in TDM separately but for guarding
the bridge or I think I was providing
overwatch for my team to build the
bridge so I think this was when I was on
allies but it was so cool because I was
like I'm just gonna I'm gonna try
sniping and it was only fun and it was
um I felt like I actually had a purpose
on the team rather than I'm just trying
to rack up kills right um I really
enjoyed it
yeah you you said exactly my experience
too which was like I love I love
shotguns there's no fun but you're right
you get to this bridge area there is no
point of you using a shotgun so you're
gonna you're gonna get out of your
element you're gonna change it up and
that's great so you know you get to use
the m1 garand and hear that famous
magazine pin eject and yeah and teamwork
as well you're you're on point - yeah I
was like oh cool I'm I'm kind of moving
in waves with my team I'm seeing more of
them opposed opposed to like that
instinct that I sometimes deal with
which is like I'm just gonna do a lone
wolf with a shotgun right and yeah like
see you later you guys are on your own
you find yourself like okay well someone
needs to do this we're losing who's not
doing this you feel like you're
contributing
but yeah I had the same experience was
like off sweet I'm picking up a sniper
rifle but I'm going prone in the bushes
and I'm actually sniping and camping
with a reason yes yes I'm like a filthy
camper yeah I need to be something they
need to do right and see if you do this
is a good moment there where when you
lose the objective there are actually
are you know restrictions of where you
can be so it's forcing you to to go to
these frontlines wow that just that's
the idea of like frontlines is very much
my like it's like that that aesthetic of
world war ii is very much like that you
know you think about just like you know
in history like like slowly you know
abolishing the idea of trenches you know
but but it's still present you know i
mean like you're still like putting up a
fight you're still putting these
defensive lines down like getting on a
machine gun like it was it was really
strong here and i found that different
and new and and yeah like this is where
I was like snapping I was like wow I'm
actually really liking this oh my god
yeah it's I think it's really smart for
Call of Duty too because it's like
you're you know how you're gonna play
ecology view there's a lot of things
that are similar from iteration to
iteration and then introduce this that's
like okay well if you're looking for
something different that's also in line
with what you would expect from call of
duty in a way because it is very like oh
we're gonna capture that World War 2
sort of feeling that it's almost like a
mix between colonies multiplayer and
campaign in that right you sense these
objectives I think it's really it's
really smart so that that's kind of what
I was wondering about here that idea of
introducing a campaign like element like
when you have two teams on either side
it's not like just players going against
CPU how do you then deal with like
progress like if you're on the losing
side can you ever you know regain a
foothold and move the fight back from
where it started in in this mode is your
are you asking that yeah that's a good
question because I mean obviously you
know this is beta like there I would I
would expect them to address balancing
but like here is kind of the last stage
where like both times I played on
attacking defending it ended with this
this last stage
for the Germans and this like that
you're now trying to do it like a
payload thing from like tf2 or it's like
if the escort the Sherman tank it can
only advance if there are allies near it
or else it'll roll back so here is right
here I'm setting up the turret an mg42
and like no one and no wrench no one
could ever get past this point and so
every time the Germans always won here
but to answer your point like I don't
think you can roll backwards are you
sure I did you were able to sleep if you
don't afraid you destroyed again that's
gonna be pretty important I wouldn't
think then I would think so yeah yeah I
mean I just didn't happen to me as all
yeah granted I I this was III so there's
probably changes between what I played
and what you played and my memory is a
little more fuzzy but I did I think
before the tank session the fight for
the bridge and that one building before
that that was one where if we advanced
they could drive us back into the
building yeah and kind of roll back
kuhar progress which i thought was cool
i feel like there should be a point of
no return for the tank because it's like
oh what does the tank gonna do reverse
and heavily yeah like yeah it does
like yeah I would imagine they kind of
wipe the tank out for that if you were
to roll back to that that middle
objective so what does that counter down
at the bottom left is that for the
current objectives that you're dealing
with zero then game over yeah oh then
okay the Nets just did that and then you
flip sides I'm pretty sure that's that
was my play I mean I only played for
yagan like just two rounds as both
alleys and axis it was it was actually
pretty cool the way it worked I don't
know if in if you were playing just like
online in the finished version if you
would have an opportunity to just switch
sides in the same map but when we did
that in like the session I played it was
kind of cool because it was like oh I
learned from the opposing teams mistakes
as the axis now that I'm the axis I'm
like oh that's a good place to snap I'm
not going to be in that line of sight
and so I think like as you play it more
you're probably there's probably going
to be a little more back and forth
because you'll learn from your time as
the other side oh for sure and that's
funny think is I almost wonder if that
was the direct cause of like my play
because we first played at the Germans
and go
push back it took a while but push back
and then oh I played as the Allies I
knew exactly what to do so we flew
through the first two objectives but
still have problem at that bottleneck
because well we didn't really see the
solution right like we already knew like
I don't know like it was really
interesting yeah that was that was like
one of the highlights I would say from
my experience but the other two or the
other big thing I think which people has
have seen is that they show that trailer
for headquarters yeah that looks like a
robust suite of activities you can do
that aren't like a highly competitive
like threatening moment you know stuff
it's funny to think is the immediate
comparison when they first announced it
was like oh it's just like Destiny's
Tower which is fine to like you know be
skeptical of but the setting makes it so
different yeah they have a really unique
spin on it I feel like here yeah that
and it the activities that you can do
make this much more practical
yeah the tower there's stuff to do but
mostly people just doing their dancing
mouths and like cashing in engrams right
totally with this it seems like from
what you were telling me like there's
you can just kind of drop in and do like
king of the hill like simple fun for fun
matches and you get to watch so and I
think it's like 48 people I believe can
just be in this social space it's like
the alternative to a lobby right yeah
yeah if you're waiting for a multiplayer
match yeah you get to mess around with
like weapons
you get to do emotes where you as you
saw there you're doing the finger across
the neck I'm up next in the king of the
hill so yeah the king Hill was probably
most interesting we're like yeah you do
1v1 and if you win you get to just hold
the looks like a little mosh pit I'm
just like obstacles you get to hold that
as long as you can and get on that
scoreboard and hopefully you know you
want to get on the top but what's funny
is that everyone can like look around at
you or the activity going on where I
guess also in line to give it a shot so
they're like clapping that's what I mean
I that was just the trailer we saw and
that everyone has seen so no gameplay
yet but yeah if you because of one thing
I think too about like killstreaks which
is nice is when you get to a kill streak
for the first time finally
it's like III don't know I don't know
what's the best practice how do i what
do i do like exactly you're gonna screw
it up so here it looked like you could
like you know try it out on your your
abilities get familiar with it so when
you get or if you ever get to have a
nice kill streak you can know how to use
it yeah I look neat I'm sure there's a
lot going on and frankly like I wonder
the judging by the destiny beta it was
just soccer but I would I would imagine
they have other things you could do too
but it's it looked like a unique spin I
think also having you guys talk about -
makes you realize like you think that
Cod where it's like alright I'm gonna
play for 15 minutes or until I get my
molars thinned out from grinding getting
so frustrated and just turn it off right
this is maybe a solution to like take a
breather and Lana mess around and keep
you in the game which is pretty smart
yeah it seems like a neat addition yeah
is there anything that you can earn like
progression wise from like you know in
that yeah like all those various
activities like dedicating your time to
them I don't know I don't know about
that I don't I wouldn't think so I think
what they said would there be like
cosmetic stuff or like accolade type
stuff but I don't mix I'm not sure
entirely they're they changed up the
load-out and class system - a little bit
yeah so it's I'm unclear how that
progression will work like yeah I can
speak on that it's so the the cod staple
for so long has been that that like
10-point system I believe was what's
culture you pick and choose however
you're like oh if I put two grenades in
here that I don't get a tactical and
then I yeah right so like all of your
perks are kind of separate into like two
areas there are divisions which is like
your class-based so you in World War two
yeah and one more to the this is the new
game so like you have you start off by
like picking one and then you can unlock
the other ones and they're like the
basic infantry which is like more or
less your overall weapon specialist
there's expeditionary which is like your
shotgun close quarters engineer you know
it's kind of a staple like sniper all
these other things airborne which is
like all about speed
mmm the progression is basically like
you level up each of these divisions to
like Frank five the endgame the rank
five is like a unique weapon to that
class which is like classified so no
nose no nose exactly that is but the
other ones are all pertaining to these
classes so like I played a lot of the
expeditionary which is the shotgun based
who starts off with incendiary shotgun
rounds he's the only class that can have
those and then the next one would be si
Rome down would be like tactical and
lethal equipment so he can carry both of
those and that's rank two for sniping
it's like rank three will be you know
one can see you on a recon recon
killstreaks previously that like being
uh not visible on the hood was just a
perk you could assign any loadout is it
exclusive to certain like you enlist in
these divisions basically is the
language they're using right so those
perks are the ones that like that I
mentioned like move and based would be
all for like airborne so if you want to
run faster if you want to climb over and
mantle faster that's that's the Airborne
Division that you would have to rank up
right and you don't have access to all
weapons and those no you do so that's
the thing about your perks are tied to
your division but your weapons you can
progress for anyone so it's like they
just took all the perks that a lot of
them are like again like cod stables
that you're familiar with they just kind
of separated them and made a more
specific again to the airborne everyone
is like very movement if you want to run
around faster that's your guy if you
want a second attachment to your weapon
you would want to be if entry if you
want to go all weapons like I wanted
more magazines I want to be infantry
that's like your basic one and then the
other system they have for Perks is
their like basic training patches that
you would get and those like the main
currency for this game is are tokens so
the more you play you get tokens you can
buy attachments for weapons and you can
buy perks for the other perks that you
like come to know like like forage which
is like pick up ammo from from enemies
that you've killed so those you would
have a log
as you play more so they just kind of
separated them for the most part and I
dig it it's cool it's a new way of
looking at it but yeah it seems like
similar to like rigs from previous Call
of Duty game like it just it seems like
a natural evolution of that okay I don't
know rigs that well from from a evident
warfare so I wouldn't be able to speak
on that it's I mean it's a similar like
class-based thing but they are they are
kind of touting this as like a new class
progression system so there are of
course going to be differences but it
seems like that's kind of the direction
they've been going in and blend up
through you had kind of like the you
picked your like I always play battery
mmm and you can pick one of her to like
supers essentially right this is perks
not like Ultimates or supers yeah so
what's the what are the details of the
beta that starts you said this Friday
yes arts Friday if you have pre-ordered
that's as far as my understanding goes I
don't think it's a direct open beta okay
I believe it's just pre-order only and
it's everything I've described
everything I played was in the beta
sweet does it for the show I think yeah
even though I didn't mention it at the
beginning we do have a giveaway this
week we have 44 codes for the destiny
beta on PC I know and you can win those
by retweeting GameSpot we're gonna put
up a tweet pretty soon at about 12:15
Pacific time she was gonna get that up
and we will pick a random winner this
Sunday make sure to follow GameSpot and
retweet that tweets and you may be one
of the lucky 44 to get that code that's
been the show do you guys have anything
else going on this week super exciting
or mildly exciting next week should be
cool we have some or Friday we'll have
an embargo lift
that's all I would say I think so I
don't next week next week we can talk
about a game that we have been kind of
chatting about yeah I'm excited to have
that happen and just keep keep your eyes
glued to GameSpot that's all I will say
yeah oh
I don't I'm gonna keep my eyes blue the
gamespot I don't know what you're
talking about I know uh I've got a lot
of great stuff come in so like she said
stay tuned and check us out on YouTube
we got lots of great content there as
well
thank you for joining us this week we
will be back next week at 11:00 a.m. as
always and we stream every day at 11:00
so make sure to catch us then until
tomorrow have a great day bye
[Music]